mucha generalidad pero por otro lado
también creo que le dio a su público a
su audiencia a las personas que votaron
por él les reafirmó su compromiso de
trabajar por ella dejó a un lado entrar
en temas polémicos por supuesto como el
que ya se referían ustedes sobre el tema
de la sanción por acoso sexual me
gustaría comentarte valentina antes de
irnos de que a unas 700 metros de acá
cerca de la plaza de la cultura un grupo
de personas se manifestó y se continuó
manifestando con pancartas rechazando el
acoso sexual hacia las mujeres del
machismo la misoginia y eso es parte de
la sombra de la que hablaba no
especialistas allá contigo y bueno
definitivamente el discurso todavía no
integró propuestas concretas pero si el
presidente está claro que necesita
trabajar con la oposición para poder
devolverle la esperanza a los
costarricenses y lograr esos cambios
históricos de los que hablaba al inicio